welcome to the one-millionth Academy
Award we are not your hosts but we're
gonna stand here a little too long so
that the people who get us a today
tomorrow will think that we hosted
as promised the 2019 Oscars went without
a host the first batch of presenters had
to point it out right away Maya Rudolph
Tina Fey and Amy Poehler told viewers
what the show would be like if they had
hosted hey chadwick boseman what kind of
plans you got later these Spanx are so
tight they've entered my spider-verse
and don't worry Bradley after four kids
I too have peed myself at the Grammys
and when Bradley Cooper and Lady gaga
took the stage for their duet to shallow
no host or introduction was needed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
little fun fact just after the Oscar
started and I witnessed saw Bradley and
Irina Shayk huddling close with gaga
laughing and chatting Bradley's mom also
joins unlike though it was just
presenter after presenter and the
pairings were amazing and the Oscar goes
to honestly I swear to God but Jason and
I didn't coordinate our outfits tonight
as actors we show up we work hard and
hopefully we take our job seriously
without taking ourselves too seriously
and seriously Charlie still don't keep
my ass we are here to present the Award
for Best Animated Short suit they gave
us one of the big one big one and we
loved when they made comments like this
why from Paris Roy muros Jeff Renan
Ellen Kenny our talent so it is truly
fitting that this year foreign language
films are not just recognized in this
category but in almost every category
some even had a little bit of fun like
Melissa McCarthy and Brian Tyree Henry
who presented the Oscar for achievement
in costume design these artists create a
pastiche of textiles with authenticity
yet never distract from the story
and solo keegan-michael key who
channeled his inner Mary Poppins
[Applause]
other presenters also took the stage
alone making points it is a true honor
for me to present this next award live
on camera not during the commercial
break Thank You Academy and cracking
jokes even backstage Mel Gibson came up
to me like Wakanda forever he said
another word after that but the what
kind of part was nice khaleesi has
nothing on her Justice Ginsburg if you'd
ever like to borrow the dragon's ring me
it's not easy being Queen and the show
perfectly ended after Julia Roberts
presented Best Picture to green books
well apparently that wraps up the 91st
Academy Awards I would like to say
congratulations to all the nominees and
goodnight to Bradley Cooper's mother and
my children and thank you for watching
[Music]